we know no cats have come down with the
coronavirus and just this week Duke
University researchers say they've
diagnosed the first dog in the US with
Coppa 19 but the illness may pose the
greatest risk to some of the world's
rarest animals ones that are most like
us humans in the Democratic Republic of
Congo there is growing fear that the
illness could spread to the country's
magnificent mountain gorillas Debora
patta has the story it is one of
Africa's most electrifying adventures
coming face-to-face with the majestic
mountain gorilla
there are around 1,000 left in the world
their numbers have been depleted by
climate change and poachers snares
now they face an even more devastating
threat a person person these gorillas
may look invincible but they're
susceptible to the same diseases as us
we filmed these gorillas during a recent
trip to the Democratic Republic of Congo
then the threat was ebola
now there is a new invisible enemy
the corona virus while the pandemic
sweeping the globe has not yet reached
the gorilla population conservationists
are on high alert vets like dr. Eddie
kambale who work for the nonprofit
organization gorilla doctors are deeply
concerned about the corona virus because
respiratory infections are the second
leading cause of death amongst gorillas
when we visited the gorillas it took us
about an hour to reach a family of 44
already social distancing was being
practiced long before the world knew
about the corona virus we had to wear
masks to protect the gorillas from any
potential diseases we may be carrying
and stand at least 23 feet away
today that kind of up-close and personal
experience has been stopped the park is
closed to visitors these images were
taken before the global pandemic here
gorillas are being treated for routine
illnesses that can occur but now
measures are more stringent Rangers and
beth's have to stand at least 33 feet
away only two people can approach a
gorilla at any one time and most of the
observation is done in a country
devastated by over two decades of civil
war there is a wonderful incongruity
here in that it also offers one of the
world's most life-affirming experiences
an experienced conservationists are
determined to preserve Debora patta for
CBS this morning Saturday Johannesburg
South Africa Michelle it is still so
gorgeous to look at those animals and
also distressed him about this potential
threats less than a thousand left as I
heard it I can't believe so few still
exist but it is imperative that we save
them such a good report from Deborah
pata